can you hear us yes
so uh yeah I'm very happy to uh host the
talk of Tony and she has a seminal work
in all areas of complexity and today
she's going to speak about proof
complexity and meta complexity a
tutorial thank you
hi can you can you hear me
yes okay great
um really sorry I can't be there it's
snowing here so I'm looking forward to
the rain when I get there in a couple of
weeks so it says so this is intended to
be a survey of proof complexity with
focus on meta complexity issues and I
haven't practiced the talks I have no
idea if I'm gonna have enough time for
everything I have to say but nonetheless
um you have any questions just interrupt
I'm happy to you know
happy to go at whatever pace is good for
everybody else
so if anyone has a question please just
say I have a question and uh hopefully
Tony hears you when we have microphones
yeah if not I hear you you know pretty
clearly so you can
okay so I'm going to start with just
basic Notions of proof systems talk
about those kind of standard ones
um I was going to talk about a little
bit about bound arithmetic but I have a
feeling I won't have time for that and
then I'll talk about automatizability
and feasible interpolation
automatizability is sort of like the
proof complexity analog of mcsp then
I'll tell you what's known about lower
bounds and
conjectured hard to proved topologies
and that a lot of them have a meta
complexity flavor to them and then we'll
talk about actually meta mathematics of
proven think proving lower bounds like
Pinot NP and what's known and what's
conjectured
um okay so I'll just start with the
typical first slide so the propositional
proof systems were defined by copenreco
in the 70s and they defined a proof
system to be a polytime onto function
that Maps strings that are intended to
represent proofs in some proof system to
tautology so you can think of s as a is
a verification procedure that takes an
encoding of a proof in some proof system
and outputs whatever the tautology is
that it's proving and if it's illegal if
it's an illegal encoding then you just
return some canonical pathology
um so you should think of a proof system
as just a sum uh some polytime algorithm
that maps encodings of proofs in that
proof system to tautologies and we say
the proof system so it's a
non-deterministic procedure basically so
when we say that s is polynomarally
bounded if for every tautology F there
is some string s of polynomial size
phone on a length in the length of the
tautology
um so in other words there has to be
some string a that Maps
so for every tautology F there exists a
string a where the length of a is
polynomial and the length of F and a is
a legal proof of x
and almost by definition the cook and
recall observed that the way that they
defined a proof system it's exactly
there exists a polynomically bounded
proof system if and only if NP equals
Coen P since the proof system is defined
basically to be a non-deterministic
procedure for a coinc complete problem
okay
um so just some notes so we can usually
assume that the class of all to
tautological propositional formulas we
can just assume that they're in dnf form
by the usual way of representing
cook you know Cook's theorem way of
representing an arbitrary formula by a
dnf
um and secondly sometimes we'll be
viewing proof systems not as proving
that something's a tautology but is uh
refuting or proving that a particular
formula is unsatisfiable and it's pretty
I'll show you later but it's pretty easy
given a proof system for most proof
systems you can go back and forth you
can either view the proof system as
proving tautologies or as refuting
unsatisfiable formulas
um and just just also to point out that
the way I defined the way cook recal
defined proof systems they're always
sound incomplete and it's sound because
uh it Maps every string to a tautology
so it never you can't prove anything
that's not a tautology and it's complete
because the mapping is on to so that
means every tautology there's some truth
of it
any questions
okay so some of the main questions that
we ask is first of all
for a given proof system which we want
to know which formulas have efficient
proofs in that proof system and we'd
like to prove since we believe most
people believe NP doesn't equal co-enp
um would like to prove sort of
unconditional or even conditional super
polynomial lower bounds or for arbitrary
arbitrary proof systems the second thing
is the automatizability question
um that's the question of how hard is it
to actually search for a p proof of a
tautology or a p reputation of a non-sac
formula they might you know there might
be on set formulas that have very short
proofs but it might be very hard to
actually search for them
and the third thing is is more this is
not this is more of a intuition is that
often proof systems P correspond to
Natural classes of algorithms and so you
can by understanding the proof system
improving lower bounds on the proof
system is sort of like tell it rules out
a large family of algorithms for solving
sex that are where intuitively with a
correctness proof of that sat algorithm
can be formalized in a proof system so
there's a pretty strong connection for a
fit for a fixed proof system like frega
or sum of squares if you don't know what
these are I'll tell you in a minute but
for particular proof systems it's
proving lower bounds for certain
statements actually tell us a lot about
inapproximability results for
corresponding classes of algorithms
and lastly we want to understand the
relative strengths of different proof
systems
so I'm going to tell you about some of
the standard ones uh and I I kind of
loosely characterize them and put them
into three different groups although
there's overlaps the first one is
Boolean proof systems
um where lines represent Boolean
functions in some circuit class examples
of these are resolution bound to depth
frega regular Fraga extended Fraga now
we have algebraic proof systems where
the lines and the proof actually
represent polynomial equalities so
polynomial equations and
a multivariate polynomial equations and
examples of these are the nullestone
sets proof system and polynomial
calculus and IPS I'll Define these in a
minute and the last type called
semi-algebraic These are proof systems
where lines correspond to polynomial
inequalities
foreign
to compare proof systems cook and recall
Define the notion of a polynomial
simulation and we say this proof system
a polynomially simulates another proof
system B if intuitively any tautology
if you have a proof in B of A tautology
you have to have a proof in a of the
same pathology where the size of the a
proof should be not much larger than the
size of the B proof so formally for
every tautology F and for every proof Y
in B there should be another proof y
Prime in a where y Prime the length of
it is polynomial related to the proof Y
and B where y Prime is a proven a
and we say that two proof systems are
polynomial equivalent if they each
stimulate one another
and when we want to compare proof
systems over different connectives then
we're going to what I'll do for the talk
is we'll just assume that everything
that we start with all the tautologies
or onset formulas they're they're always
a CNF or no it's always an onset CNF
formula or it's an always a d it's for
it's always a dnf tautology and then we
just convert
um so if it's if it's a c and a formula
we just or a dnf we just convert in the
in the sort of most most natural way to
you know column inequalities if we're
working in semi-algebraic or polynomial
equalities if we're working there's the
link below so if we're working with
algebraic proof systems we would do this
conversion we would convert this Clause
to this polynomial equation and if we're
working in semi-algebraic systems we
would do this other conversion to
convert this Clause to this
corresponding
um yeah polynomial inequality this is
actually just a linear linear inequality
does that make sense so far
okay so this is some of the proof
systems that I'll be briefly talking
about but don't worry it's a lot of them
can be described sort of in one slide so
the purple ones are what I'm referring
to is the Boolean ones although you can
see the spillover because if you know
what cutting planes is it's actually
also can be viewed as a semi-algebraic
system and then the red ones or the
algebraic ones and there's I'm only
going to briefly mention SOS which is uh
sorry the red ones are the algebraic
ones in SOS is a semi-algebraic one and
the arrows are correspond to P
simulation so IPS appears the strongest
of the ones that are in this picture and
IPS can simulate extended friggin and so
on
okay so first I'll start by telling you
about the Boolean ones and they're sort
of the most common most well-studied
proof systems
um and they're I'll just refer to them
all as Fraga systems and these are in
fact all of these systems except for IPs
are called their axiomatic proof systems
and that all of them uh the the proof
system is equipped with a certain number
finite number of Axiom schemas and Rule
schemas and a proof of a tautology is a
directed acyclic graph like in this
picture where each of the vertices is
labeled with some formula
and the the leaf the ones at the top are
axioms instances of axioms of the proof
system and all the intermediate ones
have to follow from the previous ones by
applying one of the rules and the
Formula F that you're trying to prove
should be the one at the bottom
and the size is just the sum of the
sizes of all the formulas in the whole
dag and we'll call a proof uh if C is a
complexity class we'll call a proof a c
regular proof If all of these lines are
restricted to uh they can only involve
formulas that are represented in the
class C
good so far
okay so we have this hierarchy of C
frigate systems as the circuit Class C
gets bigger and bigger resolution at the
bottom corresponds to like a depth one I
guess a depth one circuits ac0 Fraga is
you know on bounded depth um
sort this over and poly size circuit
server and or unbounded fanet and or a
not base c0p probably everybody knows
these are or the lines correspond to
circuits where you have Unbound and
unbounded Fannin and or Gates you also
have mod P Gates and you also have
negation and so on and uh yeah I'll talk
more about lower bounds in a minute
since resolution is like the the kind of
the staple the most
um the most well studied one I'll just
actually Define that one it's really
easy to Define so it's a it is actually
set up to be a refutation system so you
start you it takes uh it's trying to
refute unsat formulas in conjunctive
normal form and there's only one rule in
the rule the lines and the proof are
clauses or disjunctions of literals and
the one rule is called the resolution
Rule and if you have a clause a or X or
X is a variable and a is a disjunction
of a bunch of literals and another
Clause the or not X then you can resolve
away X to derive the Clause A or B
okay
and a refutation of f is a dad where at
the top you just you start with all of
the Clauses you assert that they're all
true in other words there's an
assignment that satisfies them all so
that they sit at the top and then you
just repeatedly apply this rule over and
over again and you're trying to derive
the empty clause and the size of a
resolution proof because Clauses are
small we can just take the size to be
the total you know the total size of the
Dag
okay and then stronger proof systems see
fragrant proof systems there's many
different ways to describe them and
they're pretty robust to different
definitions
um I'm not I'm not going to get too much
into the details but um a particular
formulation that's quite nice is is
called the sequent calculus and um lines
are sequence and what what a sequence is
is it's just a bunch of formulas A1
through a n
and then an arrow which is called this
uh what's it called I'll call it Arrow I
forget the name of it and on the right
is another bunch of formulas B1 through
BM and we'll abbreviate the formulas on
the left by gamma and the form is on the
right by Delta and the meaning of a
sequence is that the conjunction of the
AIS implies the disjunction of the bis
you're probably wondering well why don't
I just make the line be you know B
the line could just be a one and a n
implies B1 or b m i could have just made
that the line but for for reasons that
uh
may or may not become clear today it's
particularly nice to not write it this
way and just instead write it this way
in this Arrow here not this one I just
drew sorry this one this Arrow here is
not a symbol of the underlying logic
it's a meta symbol okay
um so again you can think of a c frigate
formulated as a sigma calculus that's
what the lines look like and if you want
to use a c trigger proof to prove a
tautology you start the the at the top
you label these with vaccines of the
cyst of the frigate system I'll tell you
what the vaccines are what the one axing
is in a minute but you label the talk
with the axioms and you derive sequence
one at a time until finally you're
trying to derive if you want to prove
that episode tautology you're trying to
derive Arrow F which is saying that f is
true
and if you want to view it as a
refutation system you start with all the
the top here you can have instances of
axioms of the sea frigate system plus
you can assert not f is true and now
you're trying to derive the empty
sequence which corresponds to false
okay so you can view it either way
and so it's a lot of rules which maybe
is not nice when you first see it but
they're actually they make it they make
a lot of sense so there's only one Axiom
a implies a and then the weakening rule
just says you can add more stuff to the
left and the right and it just makes the
statement weaker so if a bunch of things
in gamma imply the disjunction of things
in Delta then I can add more things to
gamma and add more things to Delta and
it's still going to be it's still going
to be true that the conjunction of the
stuff on the left implies the
disjunction on the right
and then you have the logical rules and
you have one rule in this case I'm
formulating uh C frigate proof system
where the underlying connectives are and
or not so but in general whatever the
underlying set of connectives are you
have one usually one rule to introduce a
new and reach connective back connective
on the left of a sequence and then one
rule to introduce that connective on the
right so for example the and right rule
um says that basically if you can derive
a from some things and you can derive B
some from some things then you can
derive a and b
and and so that's introducing this and
on the left so you're building up a
bigger formula from smaller formulas and
and left rule does a similar thing and
similarly we have a rule for or
introducing or on the right and
introducing or on the left oops this is
a mistake here that should be
sorry
should look like that
and likewise for the negation
so already with just these rules that
I've showed you the system is complete
um might not be obvious but it is and
but it's pretty weak proof system so
it's called cut free or cut-free sequent
calculus and the reason it's weak is
that it satisfies the sub formula
property a sub formula property means
that whatever if we're trying to prove
that f is a tautology so the last line
in the proof is Arrow F let's say f is a
dnf Formula which is without loss of
generality then
every single formula in the entire proof
that occurs in every sequence has to be
a sub formula of of the last line of f
so it has to be a cell phone like that
and you can just sort of it's just
because weakening adds things whoops
weakening adds things but the rules
don't let you get rid of them so
theological rules only only um grow
formulas and since the last line has to
just have f in it if you if you try to
weaken to you know to get something that
wasn't a sub formula of f it would stick
around and you wouldn't be you wouldn't
end up with a line Arrow f
so it's like it's monotone with respect
to
um f so the the power of a phriga system
comes from the cut rule which is the
last Rule and the cut rule is kind of
like modus ponens you should think of it
as saying if I put so a anytime you have
a formula on one-sided sequence it's
equivalent to have a negation of it on
the other side so you can think of the
cut rule intuitively as this is saying
that from a bunch of things I can derive
not a and from a bunch of things I can
derive a
I'm sorry I said that the wrong way so
if if I can derive something from a so
just pretend again was not here if I can
derive something from a and I can derive
that same thing from not a because this
is a on the right here is like putting
it negating it and putting it on the
left so if I can drive something from a
and I can drive it from not a then I can
derive it without a at all so it's like
kind of like modus cones and this is
where the power is coming from the proof
system because now if you want to prove
something you can
come up with some idea or you know
reason why it's true that doesn't have
anything to do with the formula that
you're trying to prove
let me show you an example so that
cannot maybe a one canonical example is
the pigeon propositional pigeonhole
principle
um so the pigeonhole principle uh with M
pigeons and N holes uh you have
variables pij or I goes from one to M
and J goes from 1 to n and the variable
pij is intended if it's true if that
represents that pigeon I gets mapped to
whole J okay and the Clauses State you
have two types of so I'm stating this as
a unset Sienna formula so it'll be a c
in the formula and now I'm describing
the Clauses so the pigeon there's two
types of Clauses the pigeon Clauses say
that for every pigeon eye it has to get
mapped to some hole
and the whole axioms say that for every
two for every whole J
um and for every two pigeons I one and
I2 they both can't map to J so all
together they're saying that for every
whole day at most one pigeon maps to J
and the way I describe this it's the
it's not necessarily A mapping because I
didn't add axioms that Force the every
pigeon to go to exactly one hole I just
said that each pigeon has to go to at
least one hole okay so you can add if
you want a functional pigeonhole
principle is when you add more
constraints that makes it even more
unsatisfiable intuitively let's say that
um you know that every pigeon maps to
exactly one horde but already it's
unsatisfiable in this form
um and if you don't have Cuts it's uh
it's not too hard to show that any cut
free proof requires exponential size
um and it was conjectured that for a
while that this original principle
required a large fiber proofs but then
Sam Buss approved I think it was in the
80s that actually there is a fragrant
proof and you have to use Cuts obviously
because there's a lower bound here and
the proof intuitively what it does is it
uses the pigeon axioms to derive the
fact that the sum of all the edges
coming out of the left which is really
just the sum of all the edges has to be
Atmos has to be at least M because each
intuitively each pigeon there has to be
at least one Edge coming out of every
node on the left by the pigeon Axiom so
then the total sum has to be at least M
of all of the edges
and on the other hand using the whole
axioms you can you can derive that the
total sum of all these edges has to be
is has to be at most in because the
whole axiomes say that
you know at most one pigeon Maps there
and so if m is bigger than n then that's
a contradiction but in order to carry
out this proof you really need to be
able to talk about
um you need to be able to talk about the
sum of these edges so you need a formula
that um you know on a given input to
these variables outputs the number of
edges that you know number of these
edges that are that are true okay and
that's we have to be you know you can do
that with only size formulas and so
that's why there's a
foreign
yeah so
um
I'm pretty sure that
um
I think it depends what formulation
you're actually in
um
so is there a cut-free uh proof no no no
there's certainly not a cut-free proof
and we know that there's no uh ac0
fragor proof so if you're if the lines
are only allowed to talk about ac0
functions computed in a to zero then we
can't prove the pigeonhole principle
um
intuitively that's that's because you
can't count in ac0 but the proof is
actually much more complicated than that
it's not a direct reduction to the ac0
Circuit lower bound
um and the but the question about Cuts I
have to get back to you on that um I
feel like Sam bus in one of his papers
that talked about various normal forms
he showed that you don't really need
more than a constant number of cuts
well cuts on that in sub formulas of
that but I but I'm not positive that I'm
right on that so I don't know if Sam's
here but wasn't there a a result by you
martial and funk
um
about uh
the amount of cuts that you need
um so that's a little bit different but
maybe we'll talk about that after
I think that was not the normal
pigeonhole Prince a little bit of
any other questions about this so I'm
hoping this gives you intuition uh as to
how you know what is what a sea Fragger
proof is so intuitively if you have like
an AC zero fragile proof you're really
only allowed to discuss functions
um you can only bring up functions or
discuss them in the proof if they can be
computed by poly-size ac0 circuits so
you cannot carry out this this
particular proof that I just outlined at
a high level
um
but to you know like I said to prove
that ac05 can't prove the pigeon of
principle you it's it's not we don't
know of a just a reduction to the to the
ACs or a circuit bound and the reason is
that there might be other ways to prove
this that don't use counting so you kind
of have to rule out every possible way
to prove this
with you know that show that no way of
proving this just using ac0 lines will
work
okay
okay so yep so you have this kind of
obvious
hierarchy on going this way because
resolution is like depth one frega this
is constant depth frega you can sort of
see that it corresponds to the Circuit
classes uh frega corresponds to
polycized formulas or nc1 and extended
trigger corresponds to polycy circuits
it's not by correspond I mean the lines
in the in the
in the proof are restricted to be P
slash functions computed in P slash poly
I think
okay then let me talk about algebra
anybody have any questions so far
okay so now let me talk briefly about
algebraic proof systems so now we're
going to kind of switch gears a little
bit and these Pro systems are naturally
not not for
um deciding if something is a tautology
but they're for a different NP complete
problem which is the sought to decide
whether a system of polynomial equations
is solvable
um and so so that's that's what they're
intended to do so you have some
underlying field F and
if you don't include the acts well if
you have some underlying typically in
general it'll have to will have to be
algebraically closed field and you have
a bunch of polynomial equations over
variables X1 through xn over that field
and you want to know or you want to
certify the proof an algebraic proof
will certify that there's no solution in
F satisfying all these equations so that
these equations are unsolvable okay
and again even since this is just a
different NP complete NP hard problem we
can I'm going to focus on using this
this proof system to refute onset CNF
formulas so we do that like I said
earlier by just converting an unset
seeing a formula into
so for every clause in the onset formula
you represent that Clause by this
corresponding polynomial and then this
set of polynomial equations
corresponding to this onset CNF or all
these polynomials corresponding to each
of the Clauses and if this is a three
CNF this this polynomial will be of
degree three each of these polynomials
up to B3 and then we're going to add
these extra equations x i squared minus
x i equals 0 and that's going to force
intuitively well it's going to force
solutions to lie you know to be 0 1
valued only okay and once you have these
things then you can then you can assume
that the s f can be any field it doesn't
have to be algebraically closed it can
be a finite field
and Hilbert snow Stones that's from
algebraic geometry states that in
general if you have a system of
unsolvable equations over an algebraic
that a system of polynomials is
unsolvable over an algebraic
algebraically closed field if and only
if
um basically if one is in the ideal
generated by these polynomials are said
differently if there's another set of
polynomials q1 through qm such that the
sum of the pis times the qis is one
and like I said before if these
polynomials include the x i squared
minus X I's I'm always going to assume
that these polynomials are coming from
translating an onset formula in this way
okay so in that case we can f can be the
finite field even and we're going to and
announce the null stance as refutation
of
this set of polynomials q1 oh sorry over
the set of polynomials p
is is this q1 through qn right
so these Q13 can witness that one is in
the ideal generated by the PS
and the measure of complexity for null
Stone size is just going to be the
maximum degree of these qis and we also
can measure it in terms of size which is
the you know total number of monomials
in all of the qis
the sum of all the monomials and all the
two eyes
and since we have this x i squared minus
x i we can also assume Without Limits of
generality that these qis are
multilinear
okay
um
so this is not like an axiom it doesn't
look so much like an axiomatic system
but you can think of it as one just
super simple one were you allowed to
take one of these pis equals zero and
you can multiply it by any other
polynomial
and then you can take two two derived
polynomials and you can add them up okay
so that would be the two rules but I
kind of wrote it in a flat way here is
one one big long you know I multiply
them and I added them up and it was like
just one shot oh no calculus the only
difference between polynomial calculus
and null says is how we measure degree
um so polynomial calculus you can do it
as a dynamic version of snow Stone so
that's where you start with the peas at
the top and it's more like how you think
of generating something in the ideal so
you start with the P's and you're
allowed to multiply
um
you know you're allowed to add two
together and you're allowed to if you
already generated some polynomial F you
can multiply it by any other polynomial
G
so those are the rules I just said
before and you're trying to derive one
you know these polynomials always have
equal zero on the right so you're trying
to drive one equals zero now the
difference is that now the degree is the
maximum degree over all the polynomials
in the refutation so you could imagine
that that um the degree here could be
smaller and I'll show you an example
than it was in the middle Stones case so
I can take the same proof and when I
view it this way it can have low degree
because of cancellations but if I am
forced to write it as in just one shot
it could have high degree
and the size is just the sum of the
sizes of all the polynomials in the
whole thing
as I said same as it was before so
here's an example where
um you can do something with much much
lower degree in size in the polynomial
calculus
um and it's it's sort of like the
translate the it's a it's the induction
principle so you have variables X1
through xn and this constraint says that
X1 is one and this constraint says if X1
is 1 then X2 is 1 and so on in general
they say if x i is one x i plus one is
one and the last one says that on the
other hand the last variable x n is zero
okay
um and
way that you would prove it sort of one
way to prove it is just to to start off
with X1 is one and use the fact that if
X1 is one you you take these two axioms
this saying X1 is one this one's saying
if X1 is one then X2 is one and use them
to conclude that X2 has to be one and
then iterate that
so up here I start with the first Axiom
which says X1 is 1 and this one is
saying that if X1 is 1 x 2 is 1 and If I
multiply this by this which I'm allowed
to do and add these two together and
then I'll end up with
1 minus X2 so that's saying X2 is 1.
okay now I want to do the same thing now
I have that X2 is 1 and if X2 is 1 x 3
is 1 and I want to conclude that X3 is
1. so I take this one and I multiply it
by 1 minus X3 add that add this to this
to get to get 1 minus x 3 and so on does
that make sense so I'm just carrying out
the normal the normal like linear way
that you would prove induction you know
X1 is one then the next Axiom says okay
that means X2 is 1 and so on and the
degree because I'm allowed to cancel
because I'm not carrying the degree of
the whole thing with me the degree never
is never more than two
but on the other hand you can show that
well this particular proof If you wrote
it as a null Stone says proof it would
actually have degree n
um but you can do it more cleverly in a
divide and conquer fashion and get a
millstones as a reputation of degree log
n and that's tight so this is a
separation between the two there's
actually a linear separation between the
two but it's a little bit more
complicated of an example
so again the high level is that it's the
same proof system it's just we're
measuring degree differently and because
we're doing it you know step by step
kind of as an axiomatic system in the
polynomial calculus we can you know we
don't have to carry around the degree
that we might have accumulated at the
end and the degree can be smaller
questions
um so the ideal proof system is it's
more or less the same proof system but
now we're going to measure size very
differently and instead of the basic
thing is instead of before we always
measured size we wrote out this
polynomial Q all the cues whether it was
an all Stones that's proof for a
polynomial calculus we wrote These out
as you know sum of monomials and the
size was you know the sum of the total
number of basically the size of this
written this way but you could have
written these polynomials as algebraic
circuits and here's a picture of of uh
if I took this small Stone so it's
refutation and I rewrote it where this
is Q2 written as a circuit and q1 as a
circuit that's built from Q2 then the
size of this is much smaller it's the
same proof but since I'm writing this as
a circuit this size is much smaller
um and so in papers from the 90s I
defined this through this measure of
complexity for um Millstone says proofs
and so you can see that like polynomial
calculus or no stone says when you
measure size by algebraic circuit size
it's gonna it's well
it's it's this is what you get and then
when a paper took I didn't realize this
Josh actually had a really nice
observation that allows us to put this
proof system where we're measuring size
by Circuit size to actually put it in an
even nicer form so I'll describe that
next
so it's more or less gonna but this is
the idea behind it we're going to be
measuring size by the circuit size of
the witnessing qis
I mean in this way we can take
polynomial calculus and generalize using
this size measure it becomes IPS
and
similarly the SOS semi-algebraic system
was where you measure size algebraically
generalizes to This Crew system that's
called The Cone crew system I won't talk
about this today but the nice form is
this form so in this form it's so I'm
going to instead of this is still a
rule-based view because I start with the
pis and you know I have I take it I'm
only allowed to take a pi and multiply
it by 2i and then add them all together
so it has to have this particular form
but I'm just measuring the Q the
complexity of the qis by the smallest
algebraic circuit size
but it turns out that you can actually
do away with this rule-based thing and
you can view this whole thing as one big
circuit and that's what I that's the IPS
view
so an IPS proof of these polynomials is
a single circuit C here's a picture but
C has two kinds of variables the X
variables that are the original ones X1
through xn and then we have uh I'm
assuming this set of polynomials came
from
you know there's M of these equations so
then I have M new variables y1 through y
m and you can think of these as
placeholder variables for these
polynomials okay so this is just a
single circuit and the X variables and
the Y variables and it has to satisfy
two properties the first property is
that when you plug in 0 for all the Y
variables the circuit should be
identically zero and the second property
is that when you plug in the pis for all
the Y variables so y1 gets replaced by
P1 and so on then this the polynomial
this polynomial computed by this
algebraic circuit should be identically
one
and these two properties together
imply that one is in the ideal generated
by these
okay because this is saying that you
know these polynomials
you know when you plug in the P's for
the Y's you get one and this is saying
that you know you couldn't have cheated
so you that that um
yeah so by putting in 0 here it means
you can't you you can't it you can only
use the pis or the Y eyes to generate
something
so the nice thing about this is that
it's not you know it's not a rule-based
proof system anymore it's just a single
circuit and these two properties are
verifiable and ran they're both versions
of polynomial identity testing so
they're both verifiable in randomized
polynomial time
so because it's randomized polynomial
time it's not actually a cook recal
proof system because we don't know we
can't prove unconditionally that pits
and polytime
um so it's it's a proof the this proof
these proofs are verifiable in in RP and
randomized polynomial time but we since
we expect that pit is actually since we
expect the pits and P it's probably a
quick recall system not sure but in any
case we can still show you know the same
way you show that
um that randomized version of NP if that
was equal to Coen P the polynomial
hierarchy would collapse the same thing
is true here so it's we still expect
that IPS is not polynomically bounded if
it were then instead of NP equal coin P
we would have that Co and P would be
equal to M A so still would still be a
big surprise
does that make sense
and uh also showed in the first papers
that IPS can simulate extended Fraga and
you can restrict the same way we
restricted Fraga to BC Fraga where you
you know you can restrict this circuit
class to be of a certain type like maybe
depth or
Aussie polynomial size whatever it is
and then uh what what I showed what Josh
and I showed is that for a large class
of natural algebraic circuit classes C
cips can simulate the corresponding sea
phrase system so these seem to be these
are definitely just as at least as
strong as frega and maybe much stronger
we're not sure
any questions
no okay
okay so this gives us this picture
um
I didn't talk about SOS yet let me just
let me just quickly mention so so it's a
semi-algebraic systems instead of
equalities like we had before we had
these pis were equal to zero now we have
that these polynomials are greater than
or equal to zero and we're trying to
certify that there's no solution over
the reals to these polynomial
inequalities okay and there's a positive
Stone so it's the analog of null Stones
that's for polynomial percentage in a
semi-algebraic situation that's sort of
like the theorem behind the completeness
of the semi-algebraic systems
um and again we'll always be converting
everything uh well I'm always going to
be assuming that we're mostly interested
in proving unsatisfiability of seeing a
formulas so we'll always do this
conversion
um so SOS is sort of like the analog of
Nelson sauce but for semi-algebraic
proof systems but it's it's stronger and
um again it's so you say that this sort
of
inequalities problem inequalities uh has
a sum of squares proof that these are
unsolvable over the reels is a bunch of
polynomials q1 for through qm and now
these polynomials are sum of squares in
other words each of these qis is some
polynomial squared and the reason we
want to square it is since we're
starting with these things being bigger
than or equal to zero we want to be able
to multiply them by something and that
better be strictly positive because
otherwise just because this is zero if
we multiply it by something negative
then it wouldn't still be zero so we
want to force anything we multiply the
pis by to be strictly positive and the
natural way to do that is to be allowed
to multiply Pi by any polynomial that's
raised to the two so that it's different
positive
so Q 0 is just some arbitrary sum of
squares polynomials and then you can
take the sum of these sum of squares q i
p i and you're trying to derive minus
one okay and again this is a sound and
complete proof system it's it's stronger
than all Stone sets
um and
sits well I showed you where it sits
here it sits like right here
and The Cone proof system is stronger
than IPS and it would sit up here
switch it up here
does anybody have any questions
okay so that was my really quick survey
of some of the most common systems that
people study
um and so now I want to talk about the
automatizability question for
persistence
and connections to other things
including feasible interpolation
okay so like I said in the beginning
automatizability is a is a
um that's an algorithmet question and
it's sort of the I view it as like The
Meta algorithmic question associated
with
proof complexity the same way mcsp is
like the well there's lots of different
versions of ncsd but it's sort of the
algorithm that question Court in circuit
complexity
and so the question here is how hard is
it to search for given a proof system P
how hard is it to search for p proofs of
some formula f
and if you were trying to find a proof
and you and you let's say you were
trying to find a proof of length s so
the total number of such proofs is
exponential in s so that's not so good
on the other hand for any
pretty much any proof system you can
always like have a truth table proof
that just tries all possible two to the
end assignments and that proof has size
to the end and it's super easy to find
because it's just a deterministic
algorithm so like the smaller the proof
is in the proof system the seems that
the more tricky it might be to find but
the bigger the proof is the easier it'll
be to find
and the real question here is uh for
what proof system is it the case that
you can always find a proof of every of
every um tautology and you want the
proof you want the algorithm to run in
time polynomial in the size of the
smallest proof of the formula in that
group system
so we don't we don't expect it to run in
polytime because a lot of a lot of
formulas don't even have polysized
proofs in that proof system but we could
expect that that it would at least be
able to search for proofs of size s in
time polynomial or quasi polynomial and
S okay so so the definition of a proof
system being automatizable is that you
say that it's
automatizable and I'll usually
uh I usually use automatizable to mean
polynomially automatizable so a proof
system is polynomial automatizable if
there's an algorithm that given an
arbitrary onset Formula F or tautology
outputs a p proof of it in time
Paul F here's polynomial polynomial in s
where s is the size of the shortest P
refutation of f
make sense
is this too slow too fast it's good pace
pardon me it's not too slow oh should I
go slower
no problem
I think it's good I mean but not faster
okay if you have any questions at all
just ask them slow me down
this is the search version if you're
saying this is like mcsp this is like a
search version of mcspeed yeah yes
you're right you can also ask what is
the size of the shortest of the shortest
reputation
are there search to decision deductions
um uh yeah I think that there are for a
few moment of them yeah
I think for mcsp well I would argue that
it's more interesting or it's more it's
more informative to not just know what
the size is but to yeah but if it's
actually have the circuit output a
circuit that's of size polynomial the
size of the shortest one so again
there's a little another difference here
in that I don't care about the exact saw
I don't necessarily want you to Output
the smallest proof I just want you to
Output a proof in the proof system
that's within a polynomial of the size
of the shortest proof
if you want to do it exactly we know
that that's NP hard for almost all proof
systems
so it's maybe it's more like an
approximation version of mcsp
okay
so some motivation behind
automatizability question is first you
know there's theorem provers are based
on all theorem papers are based on some
underlying complete proof system whether
it's a propositional theorem approver
which is a set solver whether it's a
first order or second order
they're improved they're all based on
some underlying complete persistence so
uh you know kind of fundamental whether
or not it's uh even in the worst case
the first question you would ask is in
the worst case can you even find proof
sufficiently if they exist
um secondly if a proof system is
automatizable and that the big
you know the big gun here is the SOS
proof system
um
it's not exactly automatizable but it's
almost but if a proof system is
automatizable then you can actually use
it to uh to get new algorithms and I'm
not going to say much about this but if
you have a proof system that's
automatizable uh so it was lots of
really exciting papers in the last
decade or kind of use this strategy so
they they for solving a bunch of
distributional problems and unsupervised
learning problems also for coming up
with new approximation algorithms for
optimization problems and the idea is
that if you can prove in the proof
system in this case SOS something let's
say you're trying to get a give a
learning algorithm okay and if you can
prove the sample complexity upper bounds
in the proof system so if you can show
that you don't need too many samples
this is very rough then uh since since
the proof system is automatizable you
will kind of automatically get from
uh from the proof and then the
automatizability you'll kind of
automatically get the learning algorithm
I mean it's not so automatic but this is
like the high level intuition I mean it
has been used to you know
to come up with new ideas for solving
all sorts of interesting like I said
distributional problems
um another uh motivation and we'll talk
about this one in more detail is it's
very tightly connected to feasible
interpolation which is a main method for
proving lower bounds for proof systems
and I'll also mention that it's the
general in general this automatizability
question uh so it's kind of the analog
of mcsp it's also kind of the analog of
whether you can pack learn a particular
circuit class
um so I want to just tell you the
connection between automatizability and
feasible interpolation which has been
very successful
um so try check introduce interpolation
has been around
um in Logic for a long time but kreichek
introduced the idea of feasible
interpolation for a proof system
and uh first so to Define this I have to
first tell you what an interpolant
formula is so it's a propositional
formula I'm writing it in conjunctive
normal form and you have two parts an A
Part and a b part and a the a part and
the B part share Z variable so they're
common
and the X ones are private to a and the
Y variables are private to B
and that this formula of this type is
called an interpolant formula okay and
if this is an unsatured formula of the
whole thing okay then what do we know we
know that for any assignment Alpha to
the Z variables when you plug in that
assignment into a and b a a now is only
a function of the X variables and B is
only a function of the Y variables so
they're disjoint so that means if the
whole thing is unsatisfiable and you
plug in an assignment to the Z variables
it has to be the case they both can't be
satisfiable so at least one of them
[Music]
I say that wrong
yeah so
yeah so they both can't be satisfiable
because otherwise the whole thing is
satisfied them okay so the interpolant
function is basically an underlying
computational problem associated with an
unsatisfiable interpolant formula and it
takes this input an assignment to the Z
variables and it's supposed to tell us
which of these two formulas under that
assignment is is unset so is a onset or
is B on set they both could be unset in
which case we give any answer that we
want but given an assignment Alpha if if
if B is on set and a is set then we want
to say one and if it's the other way
around then we want to say 0 and if
they're both on set then we can say star
okay so it's sort of telling us which of
these two formulas is unsatisfiable and
if like I said if they both are then
there's no real content so here's an
example of an interpolent formula that
Clique that you have to the a part so
the Z variables is describing some graph
on say n vertices in this case n is I
think nine
nine vertices and the X variables here
are describing a click of size K in this
example K is 5. so this is a Formula
that's expressing the fact that the
subset of K vertices encoded by X is a
clique in the graph Z
but here's a picture of like maybe this
would be a maybe maybe X is is saying
that these five vertices form a clique
in the graph Z and this side the Y
variables here are describing a k minus
one coloring so the a partition of the
vertices into K minus 1 pieces and this
part here is saying that that all of the
non-edges in this so all the edges
within a group are not are also not in
the graph so in other words
you can partition the vertices of the
graph into in this case four pieces
where the only edges are between the
pieces and of course we know by
pigeonhole principle that it can't be
the case that the same graph has a
clique of size k and a coloring of size
K minus one so this is on set
and moreover if I plug in any graph
Z the interpolant function should be
telling me whether or not it's whether
it doesn't have a clique or whether it
doesn't have a k minus one coloring
okay and if it doesn't have either then
it can give me any answer at all
so we're extracting so we can extract
computational content via the
interpolant function
from a given unset intervalent formula
and pride check proposed this is a as a
way to um to prove lower bounds if your
proof system oh I didn't tell you what
feasible interpolation means so here's
another example
um this is a very important example it's
another interpolant formula that's on
set now Z is corresponds to
um
a formula that's an X corresponds to and
encoding of a refutation of this formula
Z this part is saying that x encodes a
refutation of Z and this part's saying
that y codes a satisfying assignment to
Z and if the persistent p is sound then
you know for any given
formula
encoded by Z either it has a refutation
or it's satisfiable it can't be both
so this is going to be on set and for
and again the interpolant function will
tell us for any assignment for any
formula whether or not it has a
refutation of a certain size or or
whether it's sat
okay
and these basically any anything like
this the the
what you end up with is like two
disjoint NP pairs
okay so again cry check suggested this
away this is a way to prove lower bounds
for proof systems so we'll say a proof
system has feasible interpolation
uh if there's an algorithm that
basically can compute
um
that can compute uninterpreted function
for every interpolant formula and the
where the runtime of the algorithm
should be polynomial in the size of the
shortest p-refutation of the interpolant
formula so you should think of it as you
have an unset interpolent formula it has
a proof in P so and the algorithm a
should be able to look at the proof so
given an assignment to the common
variables it should be able to look at
the proof and basically tell from
looking at the proof and polynomial time
whether or not a the a part is on set or
the B part is Onset
okay
and
so just just want to say one more thing
so if a proof system has feasible
interpolation then you can but then you
get conditional lower bounds uh you know
you can use one of these interpolant
functions and if you think that these
you know if you have an interpolant
function that you think is hard then
then you then you would get lower bounds
for the proof system under the
assumption that that interpolant
function is hard okay and this was
actually realized so we were able to a
series of papers by many people uh we
were able to prove lower bounds for a
lot of proof systems using this
technology okay and I think Susanna will
be talking about Tony the time is almost
up oh okay great so let me just uh can I
take the three more minutes
I'm gonna take three more minutes hope
that's okay
okay
um
so it turns out that automatizability
and feasible interpolation are almost
equivalent
um so if if a proof system is
automatizable then it has feasible
interpolation that's always true and in
the other direction as long as the proof
system is not too weak the other
direction holds
and so what that tells us is that kind
of you get a dichotomy in the sense that
if a proof system is automatizable then
you kind of know that the proof systems
are simple because you can look at a
proof and say which side is on set and
simple you know since p is then simple
we can get super polynomial lower bounds
for that proof system because it's
simple and because we because
automatizability implies feasible
interpolation we're able to get
sometimes conditional super calm on the
lower bounds and sometimes unconditional
depending on the situation so you have
this dichotomy or automatizable proof
systems are kind of the simple ones
where we have lower bounds for them
um and then we have the ones that aren't
automatizable where they're not simple
and we have a hard time
proving lower balance for them
um
and so these ones in green here
um
are basically automatizable and a
reasonable amount of time
and the ones up here
from ac0p frigate iczer for getting up
we know that they're not automatizable
under crypto assumptions
um this is uh Suzanne I'll talk a lot
more about this but I just want to say
one one thing which is that there's a
strong connection kind of at a high
level at least between which proof
systems are automatizable and kind of
which so again proof systems correspond
to Circuit classes so uh C frega proof
system whether or not it's automatizable
is very much related to whether that
circuit Class C is pack learnable okay
and the same way you know if you have
crypto if you have a class C and you can
uh you know you think you have um pseudo
random generators or one-way functions
for that circuit class then usually you
can prove that it's hard to pack learn
that class in polytime under crypto
assumptions same thing's true here and
on the other hand if you don't have
crypto then just like we can usually get
learning algorithms here we can usually
get upper bounds so automatizability
algorithms
um so there's a there's a kind of a into
intuitive or I mean this is not like a
formal connection but it's sort of the
same things happening
um so and so for the week proof systems
we can't prove that if they're not
automatizable under cryptos you know
we'd like to prove they're hard somehow
but we end up having to prove trying to
prove their NP hard which is actually
much harder the same way for back
learning it's hard to prove it was very
hard to prove that you know
attack learning dnf formulas is is MP
hard I hope that makes some sense
sorry I went a little bit over does
anybody have any questions before we
stop or should we do you want to ask
someone when we come back
maybe one quick question and then defer
the questions to the next uh talk by
Tony yes
I couldn't hear you sorry is there
is is there a notion of physical
interpretation that correspond to weak
automatic ability
um that's an interesting question not
that I know of does anybody
um feasible interpolation and weaker
and physical blood circulation implies
oh sorry I didn't hear the question okay
that's what you meant yeah so sorry I I
didn't distinguish between the two here
but maybe I should say something about
that so just with like with Pac learning
how you have proper pack learning and
then you have ordinary or proper means
you have to output something from the
same circuit class
we have the same thing happening here
there's two Notions of automatizability
one is you have to Output a proof in the
same proof system
um that's kind of like the standard
notion of automatizability and then the
weak version is uh is where you just
have to Output a proof and some proof
system and for the strong proof systems
we can show under crypto assumptions
that even weak automatizability is not
possible and it's weak automatizability
that's connected to feasible
interpolation
I don't think if you could hear Tony I
can hear you yeah
so so for for strong improved systems
weak automatability and feasible
interpolation are the same your point if
and only
okay
Robert says that it is equivalent for
strong prophecies
[Music]
yeah I mean it's even equivalent for
well if we consider strong I'm not sure
what we're calling strong to be I I'm
able to prove its own reflection
principle exactly which is different
than what I said strong ones so there
are anyways
[Music]
let's thank Tony
[Applause]
I guess I'll see you I guess in 25
minutes yes